[Music]
the most challenging part of the
physicality is stopping when they yelled
cut I was still ready to kick someone's
ass still am right now ready to go jab
is very capable so there were a lot of
things that she was able to do it's
always great when you can have your
actor do it especially when it's
something where you're gonna see their
face and read the emotion if there's a
physicality that's a part of that that
the actress could do then it just helps
with the realism one of the things that
was critical to us is that the fight
scenes didn't feel rehearsed and
choreographed so we tried to invest a
real sort of scrappy down-and-dirty
quality to them there's nothing pretty
about that physicality involved running
through the woods it's dark out she's
barefoot within miles it's part of
building that character is putting that
character through so much that the
audience is leaned in the whole time
like oh my god how is she gonna get out
of this
[Music]
[Applause]